[Música]
salud en directo américa y estamos de
celebración con el campo de la
neurociencia marc porque un paciente en
un estado avanzado de ella logró volver
a comunicarse gracias a un sistema de
inteligencia artificial no así desde la
1 paciente de 34 años muy joven que está
esclerosis lateral amiotrófica que son
pues las palabras de las siglas él le
había impedido cualquier capacidad de
comunicarse ahora gracias a este
experimento y estudio del wi center en
ginebra suiza y de la universidad de
tübingen en alemania pues han logrado
que se pueda comunicar para entender las
implicaciones para comentar esta noticia
estamos con el doctor oscar franco
profesor de la universidad de berna de
salud pública doctor bienvenido al
programa de salud de nuevo muchas
gracias por acompañarnos queríamos
preguntarle si nos podía explicar cómo
funcionan o cómo podemos entender este
sistema diseñado para que un paciente
que no puede moverse pueda comunicarse
el sistema consiste en dos
dispositivos de microelectrodos que
fueron implantados entra cortical mente
en lo que es la corteza motora de un
paciente con el avanzada y síndrome de
enclaustramiento está esta área del
cerebro es la que controla los
movimientos y son unos dispositivos muy
pequeños de 3 milímetros más o menos
cada uno y con 64 agujas que son los
electrodos y esos electrodos se envían
unas señales a un computador a un
ordenador que gracias al machine
learning lo que hace es interpretar los
esas señales cerebrales entre sí o no y
esto lo hace mientras que al paciente se
le va leyendo el alfabeto entonces se le
va diciendo cada letra y viendo las
reacciones cerebrales pueden determinar
qué letra quiere decir el paciente
entonces es un proceso complejo se tarda
más o menos un minuto por cada letra que
se quiere que se quiere transmitir pero
permite por fin que esta persona se
pueda comunicar
doctor qué gusto tenerlo nuevamente en
nuestro espacio de salud en directo
américa de france 24 entonces hagamos un
recuento 1 de lo que es esta enfermedad
del el a
si la esclerosis lateral amiotrófica es
una enfermedad es una enfermedad mortal
es un enfermedad que no tiene cura que
es progresiva que afecta el sistema
nervioso afectando las células del
cerebro de la médula espinal y lo que
hace es que el paciente va perdiendo la
capacidad de control muscular pierde la
capacidad de muerte de hablar de comer
de respirar generalmente empieza con
síntomas leves pueden empezar en las
manos son las extremidades con parálisis
debilidad con tropezones y eso va
avanzando va pasando a una fase mucho
más avanzada con un síndrome
enclaustramiento insuficiencia
respiratoria y posteriormente la muerte
doctor estaba mencionando justo ahora
este síndrome del enclaustramiento que
recordemos que es cuando un paciente no
puede comunicarse con el exterior de
ninguna manera no algunos pacientes con
el avanzados e incluso lo pueden hacer
con el movimiento de los ojos pero en
este caso en el caso de este paciente ya
ni siquiera había podido eso habían
algunas dudas alrededor de si este tipo
de pacientes que tenían habilidades
comunicativas o si en cambio el cerebro
se les entrenaba por no poder expresarse
qué implicaciones tiene darnos que
efectivamente se pueden retener estas
habilidades comunicativas como lo
demuestra ahora este estudio
nos dice mucho acerca de la calidad de
vida que está teniendo el paciente de la
interacción que está teniendo el
paciente con el entorno en este caso por
ejemplo el paciente él manifestaba
decisiones como por ejemplo o requisitos
de ver una película con su hijo o pedir
poder probar una cerveza entonces
estamos viendo que que se mantiene esa
capacidad cognitiva estamos viendo que
el paciente continúa con los sentidos
funcionando entonces puede aún
interactuar con el entorno y esto le
permite poder dar esa retroalimentación
al entorno acerca de lo que está
experimentando de lo que quiere de sus
deseos también el paciente dio las
gracias por ejemplo las personas que lo
estaban cuidando creo que es un paso muy
importante para el cuidado de estos
pacientes eso debe ser lo más triste y
desesperante no estar en tus cinco
sentidos y pues no poder expresarte y no
poder pues decir lo que lo que uno
siente no doctor le pregunto porque se
desconoce todavía la causa de la mayoría
de los casos de ella
como es una enfermedad no es muy común
es una enfermedad larga pues no se ha
invertido lo suficiente para investigar
sobre cuáles son las causas posibles
hemos visto que es hereditario en 5 a 10
por ciento de los casos en relación a
dos factores genéticos algunas toxinas
como el plomo se han sugerido también se
relacionado con personas que han estado
en un servicio militar quizás por
exposición esas toxinas
yo creo que al final va a ser una
interacción bastante compleja entre lo
que es y factores genéticos y
exposiciones ambientales y que
necesitamos pues mucho más inversión
para que los investigadores puedan
descubrir cuáles son las causas y cuáles
podrían ser las curas y el tratamiento
adecuado para estos pacientes porque
como hasta ahora no tenemos cura es muy
difícil de manejar una última reflexión
doctor queríamos terminar así no esta
tecnología que hemos visto que funciona
no es aplicable todavía a gran escala y
a mí me surge la duda de si eso al final
genera esperanza en los pacientes que
sufren la walqa o en contra al contrario
no más más frustración porque esto nunca
va a llegar por ahora estos pacientes y
además sabiendo que la esperanza de vida
todavía es pues tan corta para los y
sufren de esta enfermedad qué opina
usted que nos puede aportar
si puede generar cierto sentimiento de
frustración porque hay que entender que
más o menos en promedio las personas que
sufren de él ha de empezar los síntomas
a morir es en promedio son cinco años
sin embargo sabemos de pacientes famosos
como por ejemplo el profesor stephen
hawking de cambridge que fue
diagnosticado a los 23 años y falleció a
los 76 claro que con unos estándares de
tratamiento mucho más sofisticados que
la mayoría de los pacientes que sufren
de la enfermedad yo creo que más que
todo abre una oportunidad quizás no a
corto plazo pero sí quizás ya mediano y
a largo plazo y sabemos cómo la
tecnología está avanzando tan tan y tan
rápidamente que yo creo que va a poderse
no solamente aplicar mucho más temprano
de lo que creemos sino muchas más
personas en el mundo porque la
tecnología cada vez se hace mucho más
colectivo entonces yo creo que abre una
esperanza no solamente para los
pacientes sino también para la
investigación para nosotros para poder
encontrar nuevas formas de llevar estos
pacientes y que así sea entonces doctor
muchísimas gracias y pues bienvenida de
vuelta en este espacio de salud de
france 24 en directo américa gracias
autor y gracias pasamos a conversar con
nuestro segundo invitado el día